zurück
siem einen gefallen tun natürlich wie
kann ich in dein behilflich sein
ich suche original willige der firma
edelweiß technik hatten sie kontakt zu
dem edelweiß technik ich denke ja ich
muss nachsehen tun sie das finden sie
die belege und diese firma
branchenverzeichnis handelsregister ich
rufe der wahl einen
software-spezialisten ich habe den
verdacht ist lukas was machst du denn
noch hier
ich habe noch was vergessen das muss ja
wichtig sein wenn du sagst ich poste
bist das beste feld stehe hier dann
sollten wir vielleicht den hausmeister
verständigen den kindern bestimmt
erreichen
ich mache kein wort so lukas
das verschafft uns
die erste hatte von wird direkt nach der
vertragsunterzeichnung überwiesen
das heißt ihm ein paar stunden natürlich
der bank wachsen sobald das geld auf dem
firmenkonto ist kannst du zu überweisen
aber das machen wir mit georgia
habe
entschuldigen sie vertreten
lukas was machst du denn noch hier alex
nicht selbstverständlich ich finde sache
gerade selbst durch die gänge ich habe
das gefühl dass die ice technik dreck am
stecken hat
dann hast du in rot-weiße ausgespannt
wir haben uns verliebt ich kenne marc
eigentlich nicht hat er also keine
andere wahl
wie ist das bei euch ist produkt georgia
marc arbeiten ziemlich eng zusammen ja
ich weiß es war schon sein
ich traue mir kein meter bei den weg
danke ein gutes geschäft für beide
seiten heute muss als teilhaber noch mit
unterschreiben
alex kann ich dich unter vier augen
sprechen ich wollte
alexei mich über diese firma edelweiß
technik herausfinden möchte umso weniger
kann ich finden
lukas erreicht auch niemanden bei
edelweiß technik hat es mir gerade
erzählt ich verstehe nicht selbst
versuchte sache nachzugehen
wir glauben das edelweiß technik dreck
am stecken hat lukas hat eine
verschlüsselte datei zu diesen
angeblichen technik lieferanten auf
seinem computer dass du mir versprechen
ja und das mit gutem grund
lukas weis wesentlich mehr als er zugibt
entschuldigt ich musst du noch erledigen